ten nine seven six
[Music]
well we've got a game that I think
you're gonna like this is called water
room world yes water room world it's
made by the guy that may discover my
body and I don't know if this is in the
same vein as that or if it's something
else weird but this person that makes
these games James I believe their name
is they have a great style and I like it
a lot so let's go though I am a
Christian man I have longed for Swan and
contentment in its primitive
superstitions the mysticism the rituals
I know there are all articulations of a
deeper material fact oh wow
in older times it was seen that the
order of the scientific world and the
perfection of God's plan confirmed each
other at every turn
well I still believe this to be the case
although in quite an unorthodox way
Lexia make sure you censor the Vitruvian
Man I don't want a risk where YouTube's
wrath here my lifelong work has been to
find the origin point of man's fall from
grace it has taken me all over the world
but I believe I am closer than ever to
finding the truth I'm heading deep into
the ocean
into a region they call Gasper zone it
sounds like a Mario level but okay is
Gasper zone real Who am I asking this
who am I asking this too I have
everything I need in my submersible lab
I hope to find some answers soon who
soon I will tread out on the holy seabed
with a spirit blue life into the inn
create mantle I've lit my path with the
submersibles lights it is a blessed day
before I leave I ought to fill up my
tank and grab some nets for the specimen
collection I'm gonna need both if I'm
going to do my research you got it buddy
refill tank
i refilled it research I should find
more samples before I begin my studies
replenish Nets sweet mirror oh my I'm
looking pretty good you know I am
looking pretty good alright let's head
out Oh even with my lights it's still
quite dark out here well as long as
they're on I'm sure I'll be fine
whoa sift silt I just have to remember
that the entrance back into the lab is
the furthest spot south I hope to find
some good specimens here whether by
sifting through the silt or netting some
fish I must remember that the live
specimens will try to evade me but I
should not give up hope as they cannot
swim too far away I must also remember
that if I sift at one position it would
be a waste to sift there again until
later Oh should try to find one live
sample via my net and also two samples
from sifting that should be sufficient
for now time to begin may God guide me
sift I didn't find anything I'll keep
looking Skoosh oh I found a post lip
sorry and adamite skull it looks quite
old it may reveal something I will study
it when I get back to the lab yeah okay
just a lab we're under the water aren't
we great well I need to move let's
forgotten I'm breathing didn't find
anything keep looking okay didn't find
anything keep looking okay easy
didn't find anything I'll keep looking
interesting Oh
a dive mask likely an older make by the
looks of it it only has one large window
to see from might be worth looking at
back at the lab alright I think I need
to find a live specimen now okay
I don't like the sound throw net okay
there's no live specimens here not
seeing anything oh wait oh damn
I'll check it out at the lab I have been
blessed with the bounty of research it's
time to go back to the lab and begin I
can barely contain my excitement all my
life's work is led up to this moment
black to the lab baby even though I've
been down there but briefly I can feel
God working in my heart and opening my
mind the original sin of man the
original temptation was that God opening
the mind to I'm alone here but I feel
the comfort of the Holy Spirit and the
connectedness to all things the human
being was made in the image of God a
divine mirror of creation that was made
him perfect by our sin I can feel it
sometimes in the strangeness of my body
as if I was once connected to the source
and severed from it It was as if I was
once a thing rooted in a vaster hole but
I was violently removed and left to flow
freely by my own the well as I have said
I should get back to work yeah maybe you
should
yeah all this pontificating can't be
good for anybody all right you know
let's research adamite skull partial Oh
fascinating
this person was extremely close to the
source of Genesis 2 the birth of all
creation Oh
virtually fossilized remains of a son of
Adam oh that kind of adamite sure
contains 5% ancestral corruption by
approximate calculations this human
lived for about a millennium by him and
was born ten generations after the
primeval fall hi bone density suggests
aquatic lifestyle all right they live to
be very very old and have only just a
trace of degeneration the bone density
yes one of the pillars of aquatic eat
aqua Zdenek studies is that early man
lived underwater countless generations
have passed since such a time and the
form the sons of Adam's take now is very
different I can only imagine what it
looked like to be so pure so near the
state of grace
load of the next sample amoeba
production date mid 20th century rubber
skirted mass coordinated with various
Krista Graham's biblical inscriptions
this mask would prove that I am NOT the
first to explore gaspers zone
however this area is entirely remote
meaning whoever was here was here for a
purpose
judging by the crucifixes on the strap I
imagined explorers were sent here by the
church there are certain divisions in
the papal conclave who are in the know
but some would prefer to occlude the
truth from the world where these
explorers eliminated by more traditional
factions and what did they discover
where are they now
I'll take a look at the next sample
ancient fish ancient fish damn carbon
dating 10,000 years laser vivisection
yielded fish fed on native coral forms
hyper calcified bone structure tensile
strength matching modern meta materials
this fish may very well have been alive
during the time of the pre deluge
patriarchs this very well may confirm
the theory of Gasper zone being located
in or around Eid anak ground but how
some of suspension of space-time or some
biological deceleration of the aging
process
I must conduct a more extensive search
soon I should go out for more simple
siren had it how did he get under the
water under to see what was that a whale
it sounded even bigger I should go check
outside
baby wait full stop hold on hold your
horse all of your horse just hold the
hold on to that why when you hear a
demonic cry from the depths of the ocean
of wish you are in would you go check it
why not go up to the cockpit and look
why not have a camera that goes out and
drones for you all right you know I
guess I should go home you know the
lights are out damn but something stirs
in me something should not be stirring
in you sir Oh Lord even in this darkness
I know you are with me your word is a
light to my feet and a lamp to my path
guide me okay
oh hi sifted suit o son of Adam I
beseech thee your forebears abandoned
the Tree of Life and ate of the fruit of
knowledge you walk a contrary path you
will leave this place or you will
exchange one life for another die is a
man or join God in full flesh to hear
the voice of your God is to return
origin word back into the womb where
words would fail know this now I am but
it's created messenger this is all I
know
some nerve Adam I beseech thee I beseech
thee
FSHD an angel yes sure an emissary of
the Lord amazing their visit even
matches the descriptions in live dafuq
first Genesis apocryphon what Genesis no
Parker fatin what is the Genesis
apocryphon what's that apocryphon listen
what's in Apocrypha show me show me in
apocryphon wow that's a Nabokov on to
see such sites gonna be possible but
what did their message mean full flesh
in God I can't postpone my research any
longer my search and I'm closer than
ever and I will find the truth I must
find more samples yeah how am I looking
I did nothing to say no your eye
okay with clenched nets where you feel
think any research ok here we go time to
change it up or to find two live
specimens and one object in the silt I
feel as if I barely even need this
oxygen underwater anymore baby well hold
the phone I have not said let me think
about not needing no oxygen under the
ocean sifting
we didn't find anything sifting sifting
Oh interesting this colors coral corals
colors similar to the red pigmentation I
found in that ancient fish I should
collect it okay so I need live wool
hey where'd you go boy hey well yeah
y'all got him I'll check out this
specimen when I get back to the lab oh
what are you weirdo sill it now I had to
go back to the lab and begin research
I've been interesting swimming down here
the dark and gloom is almost a comfort
to me I am reminded of Moses seeing God
in the luminous dark the uninitiated
infinitude incomprehensible to the
created mind but I believe I can know
God and I will know God I will I'll do
it BFFs with God it is strange perhaps
it is just exhaustion from swimming but
I feel a bit dizzy a beatific lightness
has entered my diffic oh god this lack
of oxygen in my brain is brother
beatific lightness to my mind the
knowledge I have gained over the years
seems to fly from me just at a moment I
am learning the ultimate truth well
there's nothing to do but press on sure
that's not a good eyeball about that
eyeball don't look so good
anyway let's research baby yeah okay
deathless fish Wow
cross analysis with previous fish sample
fish age exceeds previous estimations
born sometime in the Jurassic period
cellular growth abnormal almost
completely still stomach contents reveal
more native coral forms DNA contains
proto human proteins great amazing
almost impossible there's some common
link between this life form and ours I
noticed as well this fish as well as the
others are lacking eyes not unheard of
among the fish of the deep ocean but
even blind fish can sense the difference
between light and darkness these fish
lacked that capacity completely and more
of that odd coral in the gut
what does it mean that there must be
some thing all the sudden I feel Oh
unknown morphology 50% of sample
consists of coral polyp age again
exceeds multiple geological period
secretion of unknown stone substance DNA
contains proto human proteins so old
impossibly old the Ancient of Days time
seems to spiral out in front of me the
divine plan imprinted in all things how
old is it the fish seems to have been
close to the origin of life itself
I'll take a look at it the next thing
red coral unknown air studded with
proto-human neuron hyper capable of
creating consciousness field womb of God
error error error I can barely read this
my own sight seems to be failing
perhaps decompression sickness but it
seems greater than that like the symbols
of the world are falling from their
place I feel so the light another angel
of Lord I could feel your love
[Music]
oh pretty face water wound world okay
that is the name of the game you're
right you're right okay womb hunger I am
I am hunger going join angels join God
you know oh no I am oh that's not good
no need no need net snow need tank no
need research pedo oh must find it okay
here I go I'm gonna go find it feed on
Coral you keep no no no no more okay you
get more you want more you get more more
all right
Wow
[Laughter]
okay how does he do it how does he make
this so weird surreal and it's it's the
feel like that's what I always talk
about with organs like the feel like it
doesn't have to look and grunt even
though this day in its own way looks
incredible like just I love the styling
of it but it also is very simple but
it's it's the feel it's the feeling it's
the feeling of unease it's the feeling
of like what the hell is going on
leaning into its weird world building
and like whatever man like I don't care
what the setting is man down oh god I
love it I love it I love it I love it's
a whole experience it's a whole
experience I'm okay with a short game
it's a whole experience oh my god I
really enjoyed that
I liked that a lot that was very good
very very good very good all right
moving on yeah oh this is hell room I am
in a hell room in a room of hell a
hellish room I don't know why I'm in a
hell room I know not a hundred percent
sure don't do that don't do that
you think you can just knock on my door
rap rap rap on my chamber door why is
welcome on the inside okay this good
stuff man thank you oh hi okay what the
hell world
what the hell world what the hell world
hell room sorry
what the hell room the hell room is
going on what in the hell room Oh what
whoa what
oh hi hey how you doing good to see it
should I turn you off
good what am i what am i seeing what
what am i but one wall is gone
what the hell room what the hell okay
well if you're gonna do something like
jump out of me then you better do it
quick because I got kung fu like
reflexes and I'll slap you in the next
Thursday so don't mess with me oh I'm
gonna give you the business and the
business is good but bad for you good
for me oh oh hey how you doing hey you
you're jiggly I like that I like a
jiggly Epona because I don't like I
don't like you actually I'm just gonna
go around I just gonna come in right
okay that's apparently it weird all
right moving on
all right this game is called one-way
ticket episode one like a sitting clock
so like Happy's hung Bowl burger barn
I think it's a fast-food restaurant kind
of game closing time
take out the trash
I'm sorry hell let's stop in my way I
don't like any of anything I don't like
all of anything that's happening okay
well do I take out the trash
where's the trash oh the trash the thing
that said trash right in front of me
dammit Wow music dumpster crash I'm
taking out the trash taking it out
Chubby's chicken it sounds pretty good
I'll be down for Chubby's chicken oh hey
freak you freak down your freak that
damn guy in a chicken suit keeps coming
down here what a freak what a freak okay
put the cash in the safe okay they
really shouldn't leave one person to do
this it doesn't seem very safe one good
luck to Kirk good luck and Oh Frank
goddamn freak down freak yeah Frank
you're not welcome around these parts
get out of here you freak
Frank I'll come out there I'll say I you
wanna get bashed with the ball yo you
better run well you better run freak
you better run weirdo you better run
loser yeah you better get out of here
alright and three I was trying to steal
the money
fill the mop bucket and mop the kitchen
Oh Phil did my okay Oh God ow
where's the mop investigate the noise
from the basement oh okay Hey
who's down there how do you think you
are I don't like this I don't like this
none by you freak with your freak ass
and your freak feet get the hell out of
here freak what right hey whoa okay
alright freakin freak is angry whoa whoa
whoa
did I slip in the mop bucket and then go
directly into the fryer true wait no
stop wait wait and the true hemming is
me slipping it on the mop bucket that I
filled up and then going face-first into
the fryer
that's what the true ending is wait hang
on before I keep going
wait there's multiple endings hang on
wait oh you get the false ending if you
die it's not even worse going yeah you
know what find a moon for it I'm doing
this for you guys
cuz I know how much you want to know the
faults I think I know how completionists
do you guys are you need all the endings
I get it I get it
hiya noise in the basement one of what
that was
Hey
[Music]
do true and false in man that's how you
do that's how you do consider how short
the last two games where I'm gonna do
one more but interesting all right
this is allow me to sleep considering
the other ones for so short I figured I
would do another one as a bonus to you
guys welcome to the game in this game
you are playing as Mike who got insomnia
problems he could not sleep for the last
five days he try hard to do this but
some things wake him up at midnight the
doctor says that he has no any damaged
in his brain part now Mike believed that
his forgotten past causes to this I I
believe there's brain damage because
halfway through that paragraph it just
got worse but go to the game let's do
this hello allow me to sleep well I
can't sleep with that over my head what
is that it's not my fan my ceiling fan
so what that is Oh wants to move
interact Crouch jump shift sue oh yeah
that's my fan she's that shadow going
across my bed no wonder I can't sleep
this stupid thing whatever what I get
here we were good friends but you
betrayed me
I saw the motivational story I've ever
leaned Oh what's happening what happen
there I'm gonna stand directly in front
of this story forever opens it
all right cool good
did you know hey what a weird house okay
I often keep the other doors in my house
locked you know for various reasons all
right cool got an interesting little
style here too opposed to this anyway
who's keeping me up I just want to sleep
please allow me to sleep l to switch
late why would I do that why would I do
why would I do that is that what I'm
supposed to do turn out the light and go
back upstairs I'm gonna do it oh hey hi
oh hi hey it's just my Butler dammit
Jeeves you scared me how you doing bud
ler okay yeah it's normal
anyway good night to you too pal anyway
good night good night guys see round
eyes good knives different same note
same no yeah we were good friends but
you betrayed me it's been a long time
you must have forgotten what you did
because life has been Pleasant for you
until this time everything you own is
thanks to me you're right Jeeves bye Oh
[Music]
alright hey good night good night turn
out the light
Jana Rama okay hey what's up hey I can't
see anything
what do we do why what do I do
go feel around in the dark for the light
downstairs I want to go view I'll do it
Oh should I got it dang
lissa party time oh I can with that hey
my kitchen often locked all right
interesting
placement of everything and a key and a
soda pop delicious oh and of course this
game kind of runs like a turd fertilized
alright hey hey what's going on guys
what is going on
I had a reflection cola replies over
fleshling Cola a delicious refreshing
Cola oh you're open now another Cola for
me a key judge why did you destroy the
bodies
judge a Mansur al-hallaj
hold on we were working for a mafia who
killing evil mafias our task was to
destroy bodies which mafia killed those
people and who were your partner I don't
want to tell about it
it would be good for you if you tell who
were your partner and for who were you
working otherwise you will never get out
from the prison I'd rather stay in
prison forever than betray my friends
good call dude good call
oh the here's where I hid the bodies in
case you were worried and judge they're
right here I never forget the day I
heard you are the one who reported me to
police I got a life sentence because of
your selfishness you ruined my life and
my future I got a ton of beating in the
prison they made me wear the clown
clothes and did much more bad things
like those suicide was the only solution
for me to get rid of this hell I'm not
[Music]
sleepy this is been one Elva bedtime
story let me tell you I am just a sleepy
leap leap repressed G to go to the G for
sleep oh hi oh please don't maybe it was
a bad idea to go to sleep maybe maybe
just maybe it might not have been the
best idea to go to sleep thank you
everybody so much for watching this has
been three scary games hope you enjoyed
it hope you got spooked and just
remember five
[Music]